السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم مشاهدينا
تغطيتنا لهذه الاحداث والتطورات في غزه
والاراضي الفلسطينيه فقد اعلنا الجيش
الاسرائيلي وجهاز الامن العام الشبك في
بيان مشترك اغتيال علي غالي القائدي في
اسرائيل القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي في غره على مدينه خان
يونس جنوبيه قطاع غزه وعقل البيان ان علي
غالي شارك في توفيق في توجيه وتنفيذي
عمليات اطلاق الصواريخ
وقد نعت سرايا القدس عضوا مجلسها العسكري
ومسؤول الوحده الصاروخيه علي غالي الذي
قالت انه استشهد فيما وصفته بعمليه اغتيال
غادره في خان يونس واضاف بيانو سترايا ان
غالي استشهد برفقه عدد اخر من الشهداء هذا
وقالت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي عند
الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه لن تمر مرور
الكرام وبان كل الخيارات
مطروحه على طاوله المقاومه